- [Instructor] We're
told this is the graph
of y is equal to 3/2 to the x,
and that's it right over there.
Use the graph to find
an approximate solution
to 3/2 to the x is equal to five.
So pause this video and
try to do this on your own
before we work on this together.
All right, now let's work on this.
So they already give us a
hint of how to solve it.
They have the graph of y
is equal to 3/2 to the x,
they graph it right over here,
and this gives us a hint,
and especially because they want us
to find an approximate solution,
that maybe we can solve this equation,
or approximate a solution to
this equation through graphing.
And the way we could do that
is we could take each side
of this equation and set
them up as a function.
We could set y equals to each side of it.
So if we set y equals
to the left hand side,
we get y is equal to 3/2 to the x power,
which is what they originally
give us, the graph of that.
And if we set y equal
to the right hand side,
we get y is equal to five,
and we can graph that.
And what's interesting here
is if we can find the x-value
that gives us the same y-value
on both of these equations,
well that means that those
graphs are going to intersect.
And if I'm getting the same
y-value for that x-value
in both of these, well then that means
that 3/2 to the x is
going to be equal to five.
And so we can look at where they intersect
and get an approximate sense
of what x-value that is.
And we can see it, at least over here,
it looks like x is roughly equal to four.
So x is approximately equal to four.
And if we wanted to, and
we'd be done at that point,
if you wanted to, you
could try to test it out.
You could say hey does
that actually work out.
3/2 to the fourth power,
is that equal to five.
Let's see, three to the fourth is 81,
two to the fourth is 16, it
gets us pretty close to five.
16 times five is 80, so it's not exact,
but it gets up pretty close.
And if you had a graphing calculator
that could really zoom in
and zoom in and zoom in,
you would get a value, you would see
that x is slightly different
than x equals four.
But let's do another example.
The key here is that we
can approximate solutions
to equations through graphing.
So here we are told this is
the graph of y is equal to,
so we have this third degree
polynomial right over here,
use the graph to answer
the following questions.
How many solutions does the equation
x to the third minus two x squared minus x
plus one equals negative one have?
Pause the video and try
to think about that.
When we think about solutions to this,
we can say all right, well
let's imagine two functions.
One is y is equal to x to
the third minus two x squared
minus x plus one, which we
already have graphed here.
And let's say that the other equation,
or the other function, is
y is equal to negative one.
And then how many times
do these intersect?
That would tell us how
many solutions we have.
So that is y is equal to negative one.
And so every time they intersect,
that means we have a solution
to our original equation.
And they intersect one,
two, and three times.
So this has three solutions.
What about the second situation?
How many solutions does the equation
all of this business equal two have?
Well same drill, we could set
y equals to x to the third
minus two x squared minus x plus one
and then we could think
about another function,
what if y is equal to two.
Well y equals two would be up over there,
y equals two, and we can see
it only intersects y equals
all of this business once.
So this is only going
to have one solution.
So the key here, and
I'll just write it out,
and these are screenshots
from the exercise
on Khan Academy where
you'd have to type in one,
or in the previous example
you would type in four,
but these are examples where you can
take an equation of one variable,
set both sides of them
independently equal to y,
graph them, and then think
about where they intersect
because the x-values where they intersect
will be solutions to
your original equation.
And a graph is a useful way
of approximating what a solution will be,
especially if you have
a graphing calculator,
or Desmos, or something like that.